[Music]
the ancient history of the Mazda verse
is an area that has not yet received
much attention but some important
details and event still transpired
during this time although the theory
isn't proven accurate for many years to
come
the cinematic universe operates under
the belief that the Hollow Earth theory
is accurate theory states that there is
a tunneling system beneath the surface
of the planet that allows the Titans to
travel across the globe out of sight out
of mind
and emerges specific areas here is a
complete timeline of the monster verse
252 million BC the Titans enter
hibernation a meteorite crashes on earth
eliminating all airborne radiation and
most of all life on the planet without
their natural radioactive power source
Godzilla and the other guides you must
find another way to live many of them
entered hibernation for millions of
years while some went underwater or on
the ground in search of radiation
sources 2 million to 100,000 years ago
cave paintings show in the movies and on
monarch websites don't provide exact
details and when the events happen but
we do know that humans had direct
contact with Godzilla rodin mantra and
Ghidorah millions of years ago these
paintings depict a previous fight for
dominance that had Godzilla and mantra
work together to attack Ghidorah
or was it Dagon and an earlier
incarnation of mantra 50,000 to 10,000
BC a kingdom was established on an
island in the Atlantic Ocean it was a
place that people revered the Titans and
they lived in harmony with one another
unknown to us under mysterious
circumstances that Kingdom was dragged
under water and as a lost city of
Atlantis 12,000 BC the people of South
and China came into contact with a
benevolent Titan and started to revere
her as a daily that blesses them they
then constructed a temple around it and
the egg that was laid this Titan was
none other than
1100 BC around the Year 1100 BCE muta
Prime encounters a member of Godzilla
species referred to as day gone by
monarch and the two titles engage in a
ferocious battle eventually she gains
the upper hand beating down Dagon but
not fully killing it using her
ovipositor
she inserts her eggs into the stomach
lining of the wounded Dagon leaving them
to feed off the titans nipple rich blood
while it still lives ancient Greece a
thousand to 500 BC all those years
before the current era Greek mythology
was at its baby steps and when Scala
started to note down the myths two
monsters were mentioned that are eerily
familiar to the Titans we see today
these are Typhon and Scylla
pre-columbian South America in South
America however there are four close
about a huge creature that is half sloth
and half mammoth in appearance this
animal or rather cryptid is called
mapinguari
but now known as Titanes behemoth the
medieval age Methuselah was disturbed
from his resting place and he relocated
himself to another sweet spot for
himself to hibernate this place happened
to be on the outskirts of Munich Germany
the Steinem is now known to be the
oldest and the biggest of the Ghidorah
bit the dust
18:02 ad the first reported and
documented sightings of the Loch Ness
monster in Scotland this elusive
creature of a stock resemblance to a
sauropod dinosaur or at least a pleasure
saw this creatures now dubbed by monarch
as Titanes Leviathan 1943 the USS lot an
incident after only spare Leasing titans
an unknown one is involved with wrecking
the USS Lawton the incident saw the
unidentified creature attacked this ship
and killed every single person on board
except for one William Randolph was the
only survivor of the event which was
covered up by the government
1944 Skull Island welcomes to two
Outsiders during world war two us a
pilot hang mallow and Japanese pilot
gunpei Akari engaged in aerial combat
and crash-lands on Skull Island as a
result the two soldiers fight throughout
the unknown terrain and I only stopped
when they meet gong for the first time
August 6 1945 Hiroshima bombing awakens
the Titans the bombings of Hiroshima
releases radiation that awakens stood
nearby kaiju
she Nomura and Godzilla and draws them
out to the city to feed on it among the
millions of casualties was a cheese that
is ours wife after finding his young son
Ichiro AG spots she Nomura leaving the
premises which makes him believe that
these legendary creatures do indeed
exist 1946 Mona was founded after the
cover-up of the u.s. a slotted incident
the United States begins to believe that
finding and studying the Titans needs to
be done to make this happen President
Harry Truman provides three off booking
funding to establish Moana 1946 to 1950
she Nomura and Godzilla fighting
repeatedly the five-year flurry of
fights between XI Nomura and Godzilla
begins in 1946 two monsters are spotted
in Russia and the Philippines during the
same year 1953 she numerous L discovered
in the Philippines while the regular she
Nomura hasn't been seen in years
Mona does discover a cell for the
monsters time in the Philippines
[Music]
19:54 Bikini Atoll bombings fast
forwarding a year and a tooshie Nomura
combined into one being on Monster
Island as usual Godzilla arrives to
fight the monsters and system apart
using his atomic breath the action kills
one of XI Nomura while the thermonuclear
bomb is successful in killing the other
XI Nomura
1973 Kong Skull Island after getting
pictures of Skull Island William Randa
and Huston Brooks secured the necessary
funding and resources for them and full
of Monarch researches San to make the
trip there all the events that follow
are those of the Skull Island movie June
12th 1981
Yoshiro Serizawa joins Moana the day
after his father
AEG pass away Ichiro Serizawa is
recruited by mana to follow on his
footsteps he agrees to join the
organization and soon becomes a vital
part of the rest of their work moving
forward 1991 island of mana quarantine
zone established the first series of new
discoveries for mana they finally find a
brand new Titan to monitor almost 20
years after seeing calm they establish a
quarantine zone around Isla de Manos
volcano which is where Rodin lies in
pyro stasis August 7 1995 the secret
trip to Skull Island
Aaron Brooks recruits a cast of
characters to join him on a secret
mission
but proves to have familiar results the
crash land on Skull Island just like the
previous group but Gong saves most of
them by killing the deaths jackals 1999
giant fossil discovered in the
Philippines over 40 years of the
fighting a Shi Nomura cell in the
Philippines Moana discovers a giant
animal fossil that was killed by
parasite exposed one spot was Dorman and
moved to the Yucca Mountain in Nevada
for safekeeping and monitoring the
second however the male's paw already
hatched and is quickly setting a course
for the nearest source of radiation 1999
Jan jira incident the hatch may muted
journeys into a nuclear power plant
engineer in Japan the muta begins
feeding on the plant causing seismic
anomalies beneath the facility the
results in reactors at the base to
rupture
Joe Brody is forced to Ceylon
shut which gives us while Sandra in the
process the mutual continues to absorb
radioactive fuel for the next 15 years
while cocoon in what is left of the
power plan 2005 Orca technology created
Emma and Mark Russell inadvertently put
themselves on monarchs radar when they
tested Orca a revolutionary
communication device that has potential
to speak to tightens the reading Simona
said Vivian raha and Ichiro Serizawa to
Boston under the belief that a new Titan
was emerging instead it was a piece of
technology that could prove important to
the monster versus future
2009 monster cocoon discovered dr.
Eileen Chen and her sister dr. Ling are
alerted to a strange singing coming from
the rainforests of China's Yunnan
Province they recognized the sound from
an ancient history and take Emma Russell
and her team with them to discover a
giant temple with a massive chrysalis
containing Mothra the estimate that the
temple was built 12,000 years ago
monarch built another containment
facility around Mothra which becomes
manat outpost 61 2014 Godzilla when
thought returns home from his tour he
has to go bail his father out of jail
for trespassing in a last-ditch effort
to prove Joss theory correct they go
back to Jan 0 only to discover it is not
radioactive at all and that Mona has
built a containment unit around the
nuclear power plant this later and soon
into the events of Godzilla 2014 ending
in Godzilla killing both mutants and
saving the entire world 2014 in the year
2014 muta prime resurfaces attacks a
naval base in Guam
attracted to the bailouts of the nuclear
submarine station there she lives a
submarine with her mom and precious it
with her mandibles before Godzilla rises
from the ocean to stop her the to have a
brief fight before muta Prime retreats
borrowing deep underground the same
thing happened in France and in the
Azores
until finally with the help of the
humans Godzilla was able to kill moocher
Prime
may 11 2015 1 mana hired Sam Coleman to
help usher in a new era for the
organisation
he starts with helping declassifying
monarchs documents and eventually begins
new initiatives to further be
transparent to the rest of the
rest of the world 2016 Vidura located
Antartica latest major discovery from
Manali discovered the tree headed
Ghidorah frozen and Antarctica villian
graha leased a building project to
create another containment facility
around the biggest island they've ever
documented 2019 Emma Russell and the
eco-terrorists awakened Matra didn't
left for Antarctica to awaken masses era
which created a chain of events leading
to the awakening of all the Titans all
at once this all that to the events of
Godzilla king of the monsters and
eventual defeat of Ghidorah and Godzilla
becoming the king of the monsters 2020
all the titles have now been summon of
God the Skull Island weather by new Orca
device used by mana or by another Titan
these will lead up to the events of
Godzilla vs calm and how this will turn
up is up to us to see next year so do
stay tuned for the next videos about
titans monsters and guides you and
everything associated with them do like
share subscribe and do click the
notification you might as well bookmark
the page